[Musica]
cosa ci è mancato
più di ogni altra cosa
in questo lungo lunghissimo periodo
ci è mancato il fiato
c'è mancato il respiro
a qualcuno nei reparti ospedalieri
e a qualcuno a casa
ad aspettare
col fiato sospeso le notizie dei propri
cari del lavoro del futuro dei nostri
figli
sì
perché quello che accade normalmente
sospendere il fiato
trattenere il respiro
vorrei provare tutti insieme proprio qui
proprio ora
a fare un'esperienza simile
perché sono certa che dopo questa
esperienza
porterete a casa vostra
una maggiore consapevolezza e vi
accorgerete
nel quotidiano
quando lo state facendo
e accorgendovi cambierete la rotta bene
proviamo a puntare un punto fisso
trovato un focus piccolissimo piccolo e
concentrate la vostra attenzione su quel
punto
come se dal grado di questo focus
dipendesse tutta la vostra vita
mettete una mano sul torace e l'altra
sul ventre
guardate fisso quel punto
portate ora la vostra attenzione
a ciò che accade con il vostro fiato
non dovete respirare in qualche modo
particolare anzi
normalmente
semplicemente osservate
sono certe che state provando una
sensazione
bene ora proviamo a fare l'esatto
contrario
apriamoci a questo panorama spettacolare
riempito gli occhi di questa bellezza
apritevi
cosa state provando vi sentite più
liberi più leggeri
ebbene sì perché puntando un solo
obiettivo un problema un ostacolo noi
tratteniamo il respiro
diventando così o il predatore pronto a
sferrare un attacco verso la propria
preda o la preda stessa bloccata dalla
paura
e chiaro che non si può attirare a lungo
in uno stato psico fisico del genere
febbraio 2020
io ricevo la notizia della chiusura del
teatro alla scala per un lungo
lunghissimo lockdown un sipario nero e
silenzioso scendeva su tutto il mondo
della cultura
migliaia di persone rimaste a casa senza
il lavoro
fatto sta che proprio quel periodo per
me
forse era il miglior periodo della mia
vita artistica
io avevo tutto contratti concerti
scritture viaggi incontri esperienze
fantastiche e la cosa più bella che la
mia voce era proprio in stato di gloria
bene
io ricevo questa notizia
e qualcosa scoppia dentro di me
percepisco un misto di paura
rabbia e buio totale
dopo qualche giorno comincia a percepire
i primi sintomi del virus si era il
covip 19 ma sapete una cosa io non avevo
paura di morire
il mio terrore
era di non poter più cantare
ero terrorizzata all'idea di non poter
più tornare alla mia professione
un uragano di pensieri si agitava nella
mia mente
e due domande
ritornavano di continuo una era chi
credevo io fossi stata e chi ero ora
la risposta
è arrivata da una voce stridula che
graffiava la mia anima e ripeteva e
ripeteva continuamente 6
inutile
ma proprio grazie a questa voce ho
capito ho capito che il vero scopo la
vera missione della mia vita
era sentirmi utile
l'avevo scelto
manifestare attraverso il canto la
musica ma che in realtà
potevo manifestarlo attraverso migliaia
un milione di altre cose
ho provato far crescere il lievito madre
ma dopo 20 kg di farina sparsa su tutta
la casa
l'esperimento è stato dichiarato
ufficialmente
fallito ma al mio marito che continuava
a dirmi di smettere con questa faccenda
io rispondevo fallita o no ma questa mia
nuova attività sta salvando il nostro
matrimonio
e cosa potevo fare
mi salvavo in cucina dal mio manicomio
bene ho cambiato l'obiettivo
è come in quella favola famosa mi aiuto
lo specchio
perché mi disse che non ero la più bella
del reame
troppo facile ho convissuto con la dia
stesi dei muscoli retti dell'addome per
dieci lunghissimi anni
moltissime donne presente qui forse
conoscono questa patologia sappiate però
che non colpisce solamente le donne post
parto ma anche gli uomini
eppure i bambini
bene decido di risolvere una volta per
tutte
questo problema voglio togliermi questa
odiosissima pancia basta faccio la
visita dal medico e il medico mi congedò
dicendo che solo l'operazione poteva
aiutarmi in questa impresa ma avevo un
altro ostacolo non avevo i soldi
ho scelto però di non arrendermi e
cercare ogni soluzione possibile
alternativa
lo trovai e ha funzionato
ero giubilante all'idea di poter aiutare
altre persone
quei problemi simili
o ristudiato o ha preso un'altra
professione lo assimilata ho fatto
nascere un approccio nuovo anche verso
il canto e la voce
credetemi
tutti
possediamo un muscolo
magico del quale però quasi sempre
rimaniamo
all'oscuro il diaframma
il diaframma bloccato crea una pressione
intra addominale tale da spingere i
nostri viscere in basso e in avanti e la
pancia cade come un palloncino
la nostra postura si accartoccia su se
stessa lo sguardo e si trascina per
terra e la vita diventa un macigno
e perde i colori
come possiamo cambiare questa situazione
semplicemente
espirando
perché nel momento di espirazione il
nostro diaframma si rilassa la sua
cupola si alza e sospinge il fiato verso
l'uscita creando così all'interno un
vuoto uno spazio nuovo ma non solo per i
visceri anche per le emozioni e per le
esperienze nuove
non è fantastica questa cosa
vogliamo sentirci liberi
e speriamo
vogliamo sentirci attraenti e speriamo
vogliamo sentirci felici connessi
allineati
espiriamo
ho lavorato per 25 anni
usando il mio diaframma ma mai e poi mai
ho realizzato
questo concetto così semplice e geniale
allo stesso momento
non è
quanto siamo capaci a inglobare
inspirare trattenere
bensì quanto siamo capaci a donare
lasciare andare espirare che cambia
l'esito non solo di nostro stato di
salute
ma di tutta nostra esistenza
facendo così noi cominciamo vibrare
all'unisono
con la terra e il cielo
sapete anche la voce e una vibrazione
e nasce da due forze antagoniste
l'energia del fiato sospinto dal
diaframma libero incontra al suo
passaggio
un ostacolo
le corde vocali e dall'incontro di
queste due forze antagoniste
nasce
l'armonia
non abbiamo paura degli ostacoli
non rimaniamo bloccati alla loro vista
trattenendo il respiro
doniamo
liberiamo
espiriamo
e lasciamoci trasportare
verso il magico
meraviglioso ed armonioso canto della
vita
[Applauso]
grazie